foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
disgrace prince Andrew lots of legal
fight to reopen his sex abuse case as
his friend gileen Maxwell from behind
bars launches an extraordinary defense
is there any way back to public life
though for Andrew is he simply Fanning
the Flames of a scandal the Royals just
want to forget
delay Maxwell's bombshell interview
airing exclusively here on talk TV has
made Global headlines but why should
anyone believe a word she says I'll talk
to one of Epstein's victims I'm the
Superstar lawyer who represented 20
others
but he's one of the most explosive
Sports casters on American television
and he's now in deep trouble for daring
to say that he prefers Beyonce to
Rihanna Stephen A Smith has had to issue
groveling apologies to battle cancel
culture tonight we'll be speaking to him
live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
prince Andrew is of course the Royal
headache that just won't go away he's
ever apologized for the shame he heaped
on the reputation of the British
Monarchy he's never apologize for
remaining friends with Peter filed
Jeffrey Epstein even after Epstein
admitted child abuse he's also never
apologized to Virginia defray the woman
who sued him for sexual abuse and
claimed she had sex with him age 17
after being tracked trafficked by
Epstein if that prince Andrew explicitly
found his name in that case he was going
to have his day in court
but he didn't first he claimed he never
met her then he handed her millions of
pounds to settle the case out of court
and avoid having his day
well now he's planning to overturn the
settlement according to reports after
Jeffrey dropped a completely separate
claim against the American lawyer Alan
dershowitz he'll likely claim again that
he's never met his accuser and the
infamous photograph of the two of them
is a fake one person cheering him on
from behind bars is his friend gilet
Maxwell is serving 20 years the
trafficking young girls to Epstein for
him to abuse she spoke about that
photograph and an extraordinary
interview airing exclusively tonight on
talk TV
with the fake I don't believe that I
don't believe it's real for a second in
fact I'm sure it's not there's never
been an original and further there's no
photograph right and I've only ever seen
a photocopy of it
well she's got no evidence to say that
she's locked up for a very long time for
committing Wicked crimes the judge
sentencing her said Maxwell directly and
repeatedly over the course of many years
participated in a horrific scheme to
entice transport and traffic underage
girls some as young as 14 for sexual
abuse bind with Jeffrey Epstein the
Damage Done to his girls was
incalculable if I was Prince Andrew
Gillian Maxwell would not be somebody I
wanted in my corner her defense failed
on the court of public opinion and in a
court of law and through the course of
this extraordinary interview she somehow
managed to make it worse
I say that the Epstein died and he
should
take
their and take their disappointment and
upset out on the
authorities that allowed that to happen
and the as I said I
I hope that they have some closure by
the
judicial process that they took place
well I completely failure to accept
responsibility is shocking but sadly
very familiar whereas Andrew dragged his
own reputation as the gutter with his
own choices he spent millions of pounds
most of it coughed up by his mother the
late queen and king Charles's brother by
settling out of court now he's preparing
to spend hundreds of thousands more to
find it all over again lawyers for
Epstein's victims will be licking their
lips at the idea of prince Andrew on the
witness stand dragging the entire
Scandal back onto the front pages around
the world again
Andrew threw in the towel by settling
his case that was an Omission by him
that it was over it wasn't actually
going to fight this it wasn't actually
going to clear his name he wasn't going
to have his day in court he just paid
this woman who he claims he's never met
an enormous sum of money to go away but
he also closed the door on a sorry
chapter of Royal history by doing so on
his own involvement in any more Royal
duties and that's how it should stay the
time for protesting innocence in this
Scandal is long gone well joining me now
a socialite and Prince Andrew's former
girlfriend later Victoria Harvey author
and historian Dr Tessa Dunlop and my
son's former Royal editor Duncan larkham
and from America a lawyer to 20 Jeffrey
Epstein's victims Gloria ulrim or
welcome to all of you Estella panel a
Gloria Allred I mean well first of all
uh lovely to talk to you and a belated
happy New Year to you Gloria um your
reaction when you heard the gillame
Maxwell had given this extraordinary
interview from behind bars and I suppose
more pertinently to the content of that
interview
well I think that she obviously was
trying to be helpful
to her former friend or acquaintance
prince Andrew and uh that that was part
of her intent I don't I can't read her
mind I don't know what her motive was in
saying it maybe it's because that's what
she believes to be true but it has
stirred up quite a storm but at some
point we should talk about whether there
really is going to be a trial because I
have done many many uh settlements with
his attorney not about this case
although you're correct I did represent
20 victims of Jeffrey Epstein some of
whom had accusations against Miss
Maxwell but there was a settlement and
his attorney uh Andrew Butler is very
very good and for him to say that prince
Andrew or to have it suggested as a
rumor that he is going to file a lawsuit
that somehow he was pressured by his
mother into the settlement that you know
as they say in the south in some parts
of the United States that dog won't hunt
because that's not a reason to overturn
a settlement and further likely although
I haven't seen the settlement uh most
settlements or in fact all of them that
I've ever done uh with Andrew brettler
his attorney have always included an
arbitration clause which means that he
can't just go right to trial even if he
would want to if he if in fact he did
file the lawsuit uh Virginia could make
a motion to compel arbitration because
always there's always been arbitration
clauses and that would mean it's likely
that the court if it's a court in New
York would compel arbitration and so
there would not be a public trial at
best there would be an arbitration okay
but but Gloria on the central point of
The credibility of his accuser there's
no doubt that the settlement of the case
with Alan dershowitz she admitted that
she'd you know had memory mistakes and
so on that was a serious Dent to her
credibility if you were representing
prince Andrew wouldn't you think that
actually if the main accuser here who
received this huge amount of money if
his other case has basically collapsed
on an issue of her credibility would it
not be worth at least trying to go again
well that case ended up in a settlement
not in a verdict and the argument also
could be and of course I wouldn't
represent prince Andrew but the argument
for a plaintiff would be that
um you know that maybe she had a memory
elapse about one person and one set of
events that doesn't mean she had a
memory lapse about other events
right but it would be the last thing
which is probably listen but Glory
you're a very you're a very smart lawyer
Razor Smart I would say one of the
finest legal Minds I know if if you had
a situation like this and you were up
against it on the other side wouldn't
you think that if if her credibility was
now seriously in question if her memory
was proven to be completely wrong in
another allegation of a similar kind
would you not think that that might open
the door again
you know perhaps but I I think it's
unlikely you know in order for prince
Andrew to have a an actual try or you
know even in an arbitration he would
have to prove some kind of fraud at the
time and not only that there was a fraud
that it was that Ms that Virginia was
part of this fraud that's a very high
bar of evidence that's very difficult
for him to prove and I don't know that
he's ever going to prove it okay
interesting stuff let me come to Tessa
on this look I have a view that the
moment Andrew paid that check it was
game over in this case he can't revisit
this you know he said I'm gonna take it
all the way I'm going to clear my name
then he just caved and paid a massive
amount of money Millions we're not
exactly sure how many you read between
three and ten million it's you know take
your choice but it was millions and
millions of dollars to a woman he claims
he never met he's never had any
credibility as far as I'm concerned Why
would you pay somebody never met
millions of dollars in a sex abuse case
so you put it all together and you think
that but and it's an important but if
his main accuser the woman he's paid all
this money to
has gotten our serious credibility
issues
why shouldn't Andrew
re-enter the legal Fray it's an entirely
separate case this is absolutely classic
people going out of their way to
discredit the victim of sex abuse
look to play Devil's Advocate people
aren't going out of their way to do it
she was discredited in her allegations
against Alan dershowitz
right but if one if an accuser admits
that she actually lied about that man
and told very serious allegations about
which turned out not to be true that's
different isn't it
I think it's really important to
remember that these girls come from
chaotic backgrounds which is one of the
reasons why it's so hard to make a case
stick which is why we all have to
remember when we've been listening to
what jerlane Maxwell's been saying this
is a woman who was called out by the
judge she was called out got notes
because you don't know anything about it
I do know quite a lot about talking
truth to power I'm sitting here on an
MDA right so I understand
I can tell you quite a lot she was
called out by the judge have you read
judge Nathan have you read Nathan have
you read her book which is a made-up
book there you go
about taking so many sleeping pills and
so many drugs the weekend at kennerton
street that her memory was very hazy she
writes up with her own hands let's
recall the Virginia
Maxwell genus and predatory is what the
judge called her and she went over one
second she went out of her way
to give jillane a 20-year sentence that
was beyond the maximum guideline that is
how important was it was extraordinary
to get all okay women talking to power
in that way okay so don't let's just
finally talking now
and her brave I'm gonna be let's just be
honest let's remember
his language
signed his name too okay
sorry for the bad language that was
using only for that Victoria here's the
bottom line with this I don't believe
gilaine Maxwell at all right I think she
was up to her neck in it with Epstein I
think she was guilty as she was found
guilty and I find this this revision is
bleeding she's now doing is all
self-centered to try and get herself off
the rat the more interesting question
for me is Andrew because he remains it
was made to settle he didn't want to say
but he's a grown man the
Queen because he's an honorable he did
were you there in the room I mean I
wasn't there but I was told that the
queen and Buckingham Palace basically he
was forced to settle he had no choice
I mean look let's let's bring in
um Duncan here because and they
literally just fed him to the wall okay
hang on hang on I want to bring in
Duncan from a journalistic point of view
yeah if we were pursuing this as an
investigation and you had a woman who
made allegations against two
high-profile people
uh and one was a top lawyer right Alan
dershow is not any old lawyer this is
the guy who represented John Lennon and
got him from being deported right this
is a famous guy in America totally
different and no no here's my point and
she makes allegations of a similar
nature against him as she did against
prince Andrew and she's now had to drop
them drop that lawsuit admitting she may
have made a mistake in identifying him
as one of her past abusers we know as
journalists our Natural Instinct would
be to then be very skeptical about
anything else that she was saying right
well yes but I mean apart from the fact
that that this is the case just pretend
it's but just pretend it's not her just
pretend it's like a person has just done
this and has openly lied and then so
what would you think about the case with
another person do you think she's being
truthful well either lied or she opened
or she made a terrible mistake
of imagination whatever the reason she
doesn't wait a minute whatever the
reason she got it wrong badly wrong and
seriously defamed Alan dershowitz in the
process yeah and he fought it all the
way and that lawsuit's now been dropped
and that is the same woman as accused
prince Andrew there are all kinds of
things that had it gone to court that
would have probably needed light shed on
them and mine or stood up to any kind of
Testament time the picture and the
authenticity of it obviously being one
of those points but also about
um the involvement and newspapers more
than a decade ago when story was being
effectively sold to the Tabloid papers
which I was part of at the time and so
that would be in Britain certainly that
would put a big question mark over any
any potential victim
um but I don't think
um I don't think any of it matters if
you take a step back it doesn't actually
matter one Earth Andrew's thinking if he
is seriously contemplating reopening
this he's already been found guilty in
the court of public opinion and his
appearance on the BBC with Emily
maintenance has just has just
demonstrated yeah well that was a
complete setup
I can't even tell you what is really
behind this because you wouldn't even
understand but it wasn't a setup I mean
news and I went to him he agreed to do
an interview and he thought he said well
he basically exposed himself hideously
over an hour-long toe curling encounter
with a very smart journalist here's my
problem with Andrew about all this right
I remember when the pictures appeared on
the front page of the news of the world
of him walking with Epstein through a
path Central Park
it wasn't like he just met him in the
Park he spent four days with the guy
yeah at his Manhattan townhouse
four days and they were all partying
right lots of women seen coming and
going in that time this is after Epstein
had admitted abusing a 14 year old after
he was a convicted so here's my question
yeah is it you can get around I mean
everything else can be murky what I
can't get my head round is Andrew son of
the queen flies to New York for a
four-day Jolly I'm sure it was four days
we do it was four days four day Jolly
with a guy who was a convicted pedophile
yeah now that alone to me yeah should
disqualify him from public life right he
can't be no he can't be a senior member
of the royal family and consult with
convicted pedophiles willingly for four
days yeah but you know we have to
remember it wasn't such a big story back
then it doesn't change the facts of what
he did the second time it doesn't change
the fact when it happened the first time
I almost didn't even believe it when I
first read it because it was kind of
like it wasn't on the front pages back
then Victoria what you've said there is
absolutely a classic case people don't
believe it when establishments do the
unbelievable but what I'm saying is you
don't know about Virginia like I've
followed today and night wait can I just
tell you what Andrew
can I know what I've got here are notes
let me tell you Andrew accepted when he
signed last year last year he accepted
that Virginia had suffered as an
established into anything and as a
result of public attacks he accepted
that publicly so are you now saying
Andrew is alive now to ascend on that
he's never admitted anything wrong she
was the victim of abuse Obsession oh so
now you're saying he's a liar the irony
Victoria is if Andrew had not settled if
he had taken it to court then actually
given the timeline of this other case
collapsing it could have been a
situation where the credibility of his
main accuser had been brought into
serious question before they even got I
know in which case the whole case may
have been dropped anyway what happened
with Alan dershowitz I was I've been in
communication with him I don't know
maybe a year or so and Virginia kept
delaying her lawyers kept delaying and
delaying delaying and his health wasn't
good you know he was really suffering
and so she if you if you're innocent why
would you keep delaying a deposition
right right we're going to take a short
break when we come back we're going to
talk to one of Jeffrey Epstein's victims
live from America I was going to play
some more of these extraordinary tapes
with Guillain Maxwell from behind bars I
talked to the exclusive that's after the
break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so to come tonight who do you prefer
Beyonce or Rihanna when an American TV
sports Superstar Stephen A Smith one of
my favorite sporting pundits in the
world when he dared to say which one he
preferred all hell broke loose and they
try to cancel him he survived he's live
on Piers Morgan uncensored in a few
minutes he looks pretty chilled about it
now but it's been a hot week
but first I want to speak to one of
Jeffrey Epstein's victims in a moment
but before I do that I want to play
Guillain Maxwell from this extraordinary
interview behind bars in the American
prison where she's being held where she
says a number of well to me deluded and
self-serving things take a listen
I believe that he was
murdered
well shocked and I wondered how has it
happened
until he was going to
I will show it was going to appeal I
obviously wish I'd never met him
you know looking back now
I probably wish I had stayed at in
England
I say that the Epstein died and they
should
take
their and take their disappointment and
upset out on the
authorities that allowed that to happen
and that as I said I
I hope that they have some closure by
the
judicial process that they took place
with the fake I don't believe that I
don't believe it's real for a second in
fact I'm sure it's not there's never
been an original and further there's no
photograph right and I've only ever seen
a photocopy of it
well joining me now is one of Jeffrey
Epstein's victims Juliet Bryant I've
still got my pack with me and Glory all
right also be listening to this Juliette
Bryan thank you very much indeed for
joining me
can you hear me Julia
she said Julia can you hear me
um hello hello Pierce yes I can hear you
well thank you very much indeed for
joining me I know this is not an easy
thing for you to do
um but what is your reaction to gilet
Maxwell's interview from behind bars
well I
I people want to know more about what
was really going on and I
I think people need some deception of
the truth
in your case what was the truth sum up
for me what happened to you
when I was taking their um you know I
was promised to modeling career
so we're having a lot of trouble here in
the hotel room
and that got booked and now everything's
falling out of my ears I think we've got
a few uh technical issues there with
Juliet's uh recording uh issues there so
we'll come back and see if we can sort
that out we've got Gloria all red Gloria
I just played those clips again we're
going to try and speak to Juliet again
later but you've represented many of the
victims of Epstein I would imagine this
does bring back horrific memories for
all of them but I'd imagine many of them
will see Guillain Maxwell doing
interviews at all there's a massive slap
in the teeth
well I I would say that many of them
would like to put all of this behind
them and not have to keep hearing about
Jeffrey Epstein and Ms Maxwell and you
know I think in reference to this
Photograph that is so much at issue uh I
wonder if uh if the FBI first of all if
it has ever been admitted into evidence
in the case against Ms Maxwell because
that would be important she says that
she's never seen an original does that
mean that a copy was put in evidence and
not authenticated uh as as an original I
I'm I have never heard anything about
that and I have heard that the FBI
received it but does that mean it
actually was admitted into evidence the
original as opposed to a copy it's just
a question that I have and I think it's
a really important question because I
think if we it had been admitted into
evidence then there would have to have
been some testimony about uh who took
the photo when it was taken uh and and
is this an original uh and and more
questions that would help to answer the
question about is this an authentic
photo which would be crucial to what uh
Ms Maxwell says and the position of
Andrew and Gloria have you ever had a
case in all your career where somebody
has paid millions and millions of
dollars to a woman he says he's never
met
to make a sex abuse case go away
yes I have and because in a settlement
uh you know both sides they do rely on
evidence but it's not necessarily
evidence that has been vetted in a court
of law because often there's a
settlement before a lawsuit uh was filed
not in this case because Virginia had to
file it in order to uh stop the stat in
order to be within the statute of
limitations the time period set by law
in New York for adult survivors of child
sexual abusive which she asserted that
she was one to file a lawsuit but in any
event yes to answer your question yes
we've obtained millions of dollars from
uh accused sexual predators uh even
though in the settlement discussions
they deny that they abused our client in
some cases they ever met her we don't
really care what they say but we do care
about what the ultimate number is that
they're going to pay and of course we do
have to evaluate the evidence in terms
of what our recommendation is to our
client about the number that is being
offered now in some way of course some
CL some predators or the accused even if
they're not Predators will settle
because they don't want this continuing
discussion in the Press right and you
know for whatever their reason is it
doesn't matter as long as both sides
agree to the number that is being
offered
Gloria thank you as always brilliant
perspective um Duncan come back to the
future for prince Andrew regardless the
last thing the new King Charles wants
especially with the coronation coming is
all this back all over the papers again
around the world it's it's such a
horribly damaging story from start to
finish
there'll be no will will there in the
royal family and the hierarchy there of
Charles and William to want Andrew back
on the balcony absolutely as a lead role
again absolutely none and we're already
seeing in King Charles someone who's
actually possibly even surprising us
with his Savvy nature with with the
public how things look so far that king
um he has played a pretty flawless
flawless game but now with the
re-emergence of this uh if the
suggestions that this is with Prince
Charles support I I question that I
can't see the palace the thing about
this it's just never going away like
we've seen that in the last year that
the fact is they did the settlement
agreement but it's still in the press
all the time it's still super negative
about Andrew and it's like it's not
going to go away so you have to prove it
I think I think you're wrong I think
this is just him having a final little
flutter of his clip draw wings he's
saber rattling he did that lens before
the settlement does that and I'm afraid
this is about his inheritance
he can't lie he's a military guy like
even even what he was wearing because
he's a military
as a person right so even the outfit
that he was wearing that in that picture
apparently that that outfit wouldn't
wouldn't he wouldn't have even been
wearing that because he's very specific
of what clothes he wears for for his
truck so again that comes back to this
why not then if he's absolutely
confident he never met the woman the
picture was a fake you just go and you
want to clear your name you go to court
yeah well right now I think there's a
lot that has been coming out and what
basically like what I've found out or
other people that will really help prove
his keys this time I mean like I said
I'm actually in touch with the person I
know you are Victoria and the problem is
why we haven't been able to bring him
into the Limelight is he does have a
criminal record oh well meaning but you
are also part of that establishment as
much as I love you when I first went to
follow you on Instagram it was a warning
that you spread misinformation so I have
to put something
on some of what yeah I think more
broadly
it's a good debate we'll see what
happens it's going to keep raging us for
sure
thank you for joining me yeah well
coming up next U.S sports cards Stephen
A Smith and almost being canceled
criticizing or daring to suggest Beyonce
is better than Rihanna
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
well My Views about castle culture are
pretty clear first thing is dangerous to
society in his own way in terms of its
attack on Free Speech secondly I'd like
to take those Ultra woke lunatics who
cause cancer culture head on well last
week one of America's top sports
broadcasters Stephen A Smith faced a
social media Ferrari after you dared to
give an opinion on pop superstar Rihanna
who's doing this year's half-time NFL
Super Bowl show next month let's take a
look
ladies and gentlemen she's a lot of
things she's spectacular yes and
congratulations on new mama Hood yes
there's one thing she's not uh-huh she
ain't Beyonce
now Stephen A Smith is a very
opinionated guy and he's perfectly
entitled to his opinions and his
personal opinion is that Beyonce is
there and Rihanna is great but not quite
as good as Beyonce which is an honestly
held opinion and many people would agree
with him but there was the most
extraordinary social media pylon so much
so that he was forced to issue an
apology
Rihanna go do your thing I apologize
for creating whatever brouhaha comes up
this
I gotta be more careful where people
twisted and turn it into something it
ain't my bad on that
well Steven's new book it's called
straight shooter does exactly what it
says on the 10 and he joins me like
Stephen it's great to have you on the
program first of all thank you very much
indeed for joining me to talk to you man
how you doing well great I'm a little
bit disappointed in you because I love
you and I don't think you should have
bowed to the Mob and apologize you
should have dug in stuck to your guns
and said you know what I prefer Beyonce
no disrespect to Rihanna I just prefer
Beyonce
well first of all if you listen to what
I had to say I didn't apologize to any
mob I apologize to Rihanna and what I
apologized for was making a mess of this
whole deal
um not realizing that people were going
to react this way all of a sudden
recognizing it as a crime to express my
opinion you know my thing is she's home
she's a new mom she's doing very well
for herself obviously she's a
sensational artist and my point to her
was that I wasn't saying that you're not
great just like I bought Beyonce's album
I bought yours I am a fan right it's
just that I am of the opinion that
Beyonce may be the greatest I've ever
seen I certainly didn't apologize for
expressing that opinion what I was
apologizing who I was apologizing to was
Rihanna personally and what I was
apologizing for was how people were able
to twist it and try to interpret it as
me denigrating her in any way which I
was not doing you see I I got into a
little fury of my own last week with
another Pop Star Madonna who I think has
become a train wreck of Epic professions
and I said it quite vehemently hello and
all hell broke loose can you hear me
I don't hear you oh I think you're
taking we're having a few technical
issues tonight so we're going to fix
that ifb just a little earpiece which
goes into Steven's ear we'll put it back
in we've got him back I'm back Stephen I
think your ifb pops out no problem
you're back um
I I said on air last week Madonna I
thought when she announced her tour I
thought she'd become the biggest train
wreck in World entertainment all hell
here's a little clip of what I said here
we go
see I don't even care I don't need to
like singers to enjoy them at all in
fact quite the opposite I don't need to
like any artist to enjoy them but in her
case I find her behavior for a woman in
her 60s just utterly embarrassing I mean
if that was my mother you'd be like
cringing
now that was my honestly held opinion
Stephen about Madonna people can
disagree you might disagree but
certainly I had a huge blowback from
people Madonna fans and so on calling me
all sorts of stuff want him in cancel I
want to be shame for being a misogynist
exercise it was none of those things I
just think she does things deliberately
to provoke and I find them pretty uh
revolting actually now here's the point
here's my point here's the deal it would
never have crossed my mind to apologize
and I just thought that knowing you and
I'm such a fan of yours I was surprised
you felt you needed to
I thought I needed to because I think
that if you're Rihanna's sitting home
minding your business you interpreted it
maybe without seeing it yourself as
people expressing sentiments that I was
disrespectful to her which I did not do
and my point is a lot of times you have
people that are subjected to the
headlines Without Really knowing the the
details of the content that's been
disseminated so I wanted to make sure
that she understand exactly where I was
coming from that I was a fan of hers I'm
just a bigger fan of Beyonce and I'm not
apologizing for that to anybody having
said all of that your point about
Madonna here's where I would compare the
two you were talking about Madonna as a
person and how she conducts herself and
you are entitled to your opinion and
people are entitled to disagree and even
be offended by that my point is what did
I say about Rihanna that was offensive I
think she's great and Sensational and
that she's done great I said nothing
offensive about her and so for people to
interpret that if she didn't see it
herself she might have just went with
these fools out there with this Walt
culture that goes to the extreme and I
wanted to make sure that I addressed it
directly and apologized to her for
creating this stir but in the same
breath please understand I am not
someone who is fearful of the right or
the left to the extreme what culture
doesn't fear me they can all kiss off
I'm not here to make friends and and
subject what I feel good suppress what I
feel because I'm fearful about how
somebody is going to react it's just
that I wanted Rihanna to make sure she
knew I wanted to make sure she knew in
no way that I intend any disrespect
towards her everybody else could kick
rocks I'm not worried about what
well very glad to hear it um because
that's more like the Stephen uh Smith
than I know but let me ask you this what
does this say about wider society that
you can go on a show as you did to
promote your excellent book and just
make a genuine honest observation that
you think Beyonce is the biggest star of
a kind in the world and that Rihanna may
not be quite at that level but is still
great and that creates a gigantic
Firestorm driven by social media what
does this say about where we've gone to
as a society
it says several things hey people don't
have a lot of things going on in their
life they have nothing better to do or
number two they're entirely too Petty or
number three they're feigning passion
and vitriol or what have you because
it's click bait material and everybody's
looking to find a way to monetize uh
whatever they're doing
um as opposed to going out there and
really putting in the work and making
something of themselves that's not to
say that everybody that feels that way
are that way because I'm certainly not
trying to imply that but I would like to
believe that most most people in this
world have better things to do with
their time than creating a controversy
out of something this minuscule and
innocuous comedians that's different I
mean you're making jokes you see you
react to it you're making people laugh
and stuff like that but I'm talking
about the natural organic authentic
uproar over something that there was
nothing to have an uproar about but
that's the society that we're living in
because those are people on the fringes
whether it's the extreme being right or
the extreme left they make up about
eight percent of the population no
matter which side you lean to and
unfortunately the ones who Screech the
louder so the ones who get the most
attention as opposed to the vast
majority of us who have some damn sense
that's really what the situation is and
that's what you have to deal with it
what is the answer it's unfortunate it's
sad at that time but you deal with it
Stephen what is the answer to this
canceled culture which is enveloped
Society not just in the States but over
here in the UK around the world actually
what it is you know Elon Musk has called
it the woke virus where people feel this
immediate inclination if they hear an
opinion they don't like or don't agree
with to want to shame and vilify that
person get them hounded out of their job
ruin their lives if they can they take
great Glee in that
what do we do about it how do we stop it
you
you have to shame the petty into the
petty holes they belong in and those of
us who have some sense uh have some
decorum and are relatively reasonable we
need to make sure that our voices are
just as loud if not louder than theirs
if somebody is loud and obnoxious and
you never hear anybody else sure they're
going to come across as profound in some
people's eyes because they're getting
that shine that level of attention but
when you give attention to those who are
worthy of it who make more sense who
exercise more common sense and decency
and decorum Etc then obviously those
people will weed itself out stop
allowing these people to monetize such
certain situations make money off of the
pettiness and and the vitriol make sure
that they got to go out there and earn
their money the old-fashioned way and
then you'll see people preoccupying
themselves with other things instead of
this kind of nonsense that I was
subjected to last week out of Interest
did you hear from either Beyonce or
Rihanna personally
no no no I didn't because I I had my own
little run-in with Rihanna it was quite
feisty uh this was a few years ago she
she performed I didn't know that she
performed at a Paralympics event uh and
was fantastic but she cut her hair very
short and I uh rather cheekily I admit I
went on Twitter and said I think Rihanna
should grow her hair back fast and she
replied by she came off stage actually
and immediately replied to me you should
grow your bleep
fast referring to a a lower part of my
abdominal region
well well let me say this to you I I I I
don't agree with that come back
but I would but I would but I would tell
you this I would tell you this I also
don't agree with your assertion of
Rihanna Rihanna on her worst day looks
better than most women she is a very
very beautiful you know what I actually
don't disagree with him here and I
definitely think that you I actually
think that you are a bit off-kilter
there it's pretty hard to find a woman
more beautiful than Rihanna I think you
crossed the line there I think you
raised a very good point uh Mr Smith
tell me quickly about your book uh
because you wrote a book and it's called
straight shooter I wrote a book called
shooting straight so I think we are
Kindred Spirits uh in many ways and
agree probably about a lot more than we
disagree about but if you were selling
your book you know giving a a sort of a
sales pitch what would you say to people
as to why they should go and buy it
um I think that it's a motivational book
it's an inspirational book uh uh if
you're young or old and the odds are
stacked against you and you're down and
people are telling you you're out that
there's no way to climb from the bottom
from the abyss um to or to ascend to new
heights they're wrong the fact of the
matter is you put your head down you're
focused you've got a plan there's always
somebody out there to help you help give
you a helping hand and to give you that
motivation to move forward and that's
what I want people to get out of this to
understand that there's a lot of us in
this world that go through a lot of
trials and tribulations but you don't
stand still you don't lay down and just
accept uh the dormant consequences of
your of your life or your actions at
that particular moment in time as long
as you're living and breathing you got
an opportunity to get up and make
tomorrow and the next day and the day
after that a hell of a lot better than
past days were that's the kind of
message that I want people to appeal
from this book I love it Stephen A Smith
what a pleasure to have you on the show
please come back I loved that segment
thank you very much my pleasure my
pleasure take care
what interesting guy inspiring guy too
well next time joined by tonight's pack
not a politics sleaze again yawn but
we'll get into it we'll work out who
should have to resign they're always
resigning aren't they and they're always
lazy is it the end of the story
government ready we've always had enough
of it we all just squeezed out are they
just a bunch of sleeve balls we'll
debate that after the break
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back with my pack tonight here
with talk TV contributors Esther cracker
and Paula Ryan agent well welcome to you
ladies uh Stephen A Smith he's a smart
guy yeah really funny interesting funny
yeah but even he who does a book called
straight shooter even he gets basically
bullied into apologizing for basically
just saying he prefers Beyonce dies he
didn't apologize and he told you he
didn't apologize
it's a three-minute apology because he
was concerned that she made missing
exactly yeah
Beyonce or Rihanna
very private thing
really
I don't think the nation's quite ready
for me twerking on the table I think you
underestimated talking you're singing uh
Sam Smith uh he they them she whatever
he currently calls himself she does
whatever they see I can't call one
person there yeah I have a problem with
that there's only one you can't get your
head around it
they can't either because they keep
practically incorrect their minds what
they are no it's not their problem it's
your problem they was a gay man came out
as gay then he said actually I'm now
non-binary yes then then something else
and now they have got the goal to come
out and say that the Brit Awards Fiasco
where all the nominees are better of
course are men because they made it
gender neutral so the men dominating so
you're accepting about the sex
discrimination that still exists
how can I say that a woman because the
five years
because the fire as well oh so you make
it gender neutral to avoid
discrimination and when the five best
artist nominations actually turn out to
be men that year that's discrimination
against women but no one was surprised
what about going back to having best
women and best men which was what old
Sam Smith they wanted to stop right they
wanted it to stop they wanted non-binary
to get the same part of the pie as men
and women and guess what now he wants
more women to be nominated really Sam
Smith they
the reality is and the reason why you're
getting so tired the reason why you're
exhausting and it's true it's exhausting
it's true because somebody's gay one
minute the non-binary of the next they
want women removed from award ceremonies
they'll want gender neutral Awards and
then when it turns out that no women get
nominated that becomes sexism then he
then they wants to have them
the whole thing and this is the problem
there is no such thing as awoke War this
is you oh no there is
an exhausted there is about a myth no
there is we need to dispel that no no
okay this is
about them discovering going on a
journey
it is ridiculous and you need to keep up
with that and you're strong
we don't need to stop I can't actually
keep up with Sam Smith yeah they change
their identity so often from he to she
to they to whatever ever I can't keep up
with it and why did why does that why
should I have to and why does that why
should I have to how many women do you
think were asked for their permission to
whether they think the women's category
should be removed exactly how many women
do you think
the whole thing was ridiculous
that decision was made effectively by
people backing this man it is it is
literally the patriarchy the fact that
one confused man which is what Sam Smith
is said oh but we don't want to identify
as male or female and so they removed
the female I'm not sure
I was obviously confused I I I'm not
sure he would agree with you as
definitely well yeah
you just misgendered Sam Smith I did and
I apologize please apologize today I
apologize
today please
I didn't mean to do that you see how
easy it is it is easy but what we need
to do is have this conversation
that's not helpful if I said my pronoun
was hottest man alive if they was that
was my genuine pronoun would you feel
obliged to call me that every day hey
hottest man alive no you wouldn't no so
in other words it all depends who
decides what they want to be isn't that
what we're discussing the fact that I
don't have to do that but why do we have
to go why do we have to call Sam Smith
because we're respecting this
that's my choice
hottest man alive hottest man alive all
the time that is my choice and I demand
you respect it
well I once identified as a two-spirit
penguin because I was told there are a
hundred genders including astragender
which is an affinity with the Stars and
I was told peers stop being ridiculous I
was like if there are 100 genders I can
be a two-spirit penguin I can now demand
you call me is my pronouns hardest man
alive but you don't want to because you
think that's ridiculous serious part of
this question a single person they and
them the serious part of this
conversation is about people who do not
fit into your box and you struggle with
that here's where I struggle struggle
with yeah let me answer here's my
problem with Sam Smith
they said when they weren't actually
they when they were a gay man they said
we need to even up these award
ceremonies by making them all gender
neutral I demand it it's now happened
and they as the former gay man that
wants us to call him now says it's
terribly unfair and we've got to have
more women they are responsible for
where we've got to because changing a
name doesn't change the distance
but you know what the good thing about
the tour is there's always time tomorrow
because there'll be more of it by
tomorrow
keep it unsensitive
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign